Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No claiming to be, or
to have ever been, Steve Irwin!
How dare you?
Steve Irwin was an international treasure,
and you will never, ever fill his sensible
shoes, Dr. Bright.
No matter how much you say "crikey" when looking
at SCP-682, no matter how many times you call
it a "mighty big croc!", no matter how much
you photoshop yourself into photos of SCP-682
or how many Australians you possess, you will
never be The Crocodile Hunter.
Stop trying to make it happen, no one is going
to call you that.
And stop tricking interns into buying autographed
memorabilia from you, we all know it's a forgery.